mi siento como independent yo you need
anything just so it director independent
assessment yeah even you're all going to
pay lik Willis well cheaper am in O chem
importers cantar una storia Buena a
please Jonah said como paso esto apron
tempest at raha Hollywood in Hollywood
in makovica me professor a mentor as
Mississippi risky sister su carrera
stanley pero como paso esta bueno por
que - el proyecto condi his nikon
universal pero me intense yo no era
mover - mundo see no party here now when
I story on Elena película evidently
meant a I'm a you da Mucha tener Esther
reconocimiento international you know
sighs hola todos pero no no I eunuch oh
sorry data entry cows I affect inter
says I own reconocimiento I mean por
supuesto a key and the key so you know
product or a ki baat aakar o proyectos
de calidad he yes come on resuming the
que de todo lo que h is soon Aviles
Pecos Lima Carrera no creo mucho la
co-production Y sigue siendo
co-production is con America latina
Caracas unum push model the dirty cooler
nuestra cinematography as también el
exhibition no solo produce siendo SI no
te guarantees adele una manera que el
otro país tambien ba Asuran grannies for
super soccer la película imma go stretch
it to form our las nubes generaciones
tambien básicamente porque me dinner tow
como loca como Anana porque soy me teach
a yo tengo la oportunidad de meter las
manos imposes a heinous Yemeni Arliss
eaters zero porky very stupid cerebro so
kind of is still necessary a lady on
scene to come on last never gonna come
up on dawn atomic wasabi okay set the
bar cuz it every he said to disturb but
upon the various is so alien his mood
efficient me thirty in in the cabeza de
la otra gente y cuando lo lo groom
decent okay yellow King and cheaper than
the key little hiccup oh no sir I'm a
[ __ ] Arlo transform Arlo just with me
teaching you see you know Isis hora muy
intrusive anodic respite oh he knows
deleted apostle dis Petofi no nada look
if you pierce academic or possibly
yellow well decidirá
yell contrary to pienso que que este
ascent own a perception in tratar de
tratar de descubrir pequeños de taille
hell Arella dad no tienen que ver con
una presion do mundo personal intimacy
no tambien do una postural política
respect o de de la realidad como algo
que puede ser tranform odd oh no no
accepted he really dad como I'll go okay
okay okay Kay so meter say no bueno
ahem bro siempre son esse francais como
la pauvre say structural idea como él
hace Uno's save a so metiendo como si
fuera impossible Arabic are no pienso
que el can see Nadal oportunidad
a los victorious he yell a hint a Chanel
que trabajan cine they were sad in la
tavola visual communal remain today
they take the key ever end ella
perception ESO a who noxian política no
pienso que perder el oportunidad de se
DISA accion st profunda political
tsunami not my purview
[Music]
good evening my name is Randy Hebert
camp I'm the managing director of
preservation and foundation programs for
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences and I will be the last man you
see on this stage tonight so I think
that's a good thing anyway welcome I
want to tell you a few things about
what's going on here because I am
officially adopting you all as disciples
of our program here tonight and to
spread the word about what is going on
at the Academy and also throughout
Southern California thanks to the very
great generosity of the Getty we're very
happy to be part of Pacific Standard
Time Latin America Los Angeles which the
Getty has invented and has allowed 70
arts organizations to participate I'm
very happy that we are one of three film
organizations that are part of this arts
festival because film is an art and
that's why in 1927 90 years ago they
called this the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences
so we're still fighting that battle a
little bit but at the same time we're
very happy to be part of this we're very
happy to have a very extensive program
and I want you to understand the
complexity of it you just saw some
samples from our oral histories that
were recorded specifically because of
the Gettys program we've been working on
this for three and a half years we
traveled to Cuba to not to keep it we
yes actually we did travel to Cuba but
we've recorded histories with filmmakers
from Cuba Brazil Mexico Argentina and
also of course Los Angeles we even did
some oral histories in London because
filmmakers were working there so this is
continuing we did 13 we've done 13 more
and this these are all right now there's
13 of them viewable online you can hear
the entire story of these film a
there's lives and careers so I hope you
go there and and look for it on Oscars
org we will be adding more to it
we have also published a book that is
downloadable free as an e-book and
there's some copies that a few of you
will get tonight so look for that book
and look for the scholarly approach that
it takes to these oral histories we are
doing 12 Monday nights in a row starting
this Monday with zoot suit Louie's
spelled des will be here edward james
olmos will be here we will have brand
new screening of that and we are also
premiering the restoration of IM joaquin
lewis Valdez's first 20-minute film
basically considered to be the first
Chicano film will be here on the big
screen where it belongs and again 12
more screenings after that also some
Saturday screenings you've got a program
that has all the listings please come to
them if you were a teacher if you are a
student if you are a parent whose kids
need to understand what came before them
this is where we want you to come and
bring them this is the experience they
should have with these films on the big
screen that they were made for we are
not just screening movies we will be
having clips we will be having music we
will be having interviews we will be
having all kinds of surprises please
come please do everything you can to
talk about this festival and get people
to understand it it's hard to get the
word out because people say oh I've seen
that movie
this isn't about seeing a movie this is
about experiencing a movie okay with
your fellow audience members
understanding the emotion feeling the
cinema come alive on the screen okay so
without further ado I want to introduce
the woman who helped us curate this
series some people look at this series
and they go why aren't you showing this
film or why you're showing that film
well the answer is we only have so many
nights that we can show films that's
part of it the other part of it is
Lourdes really wanted this to be a
series that
number one reflected a variety of
countries a variety of filmmakers and
people who had very specific voices she
also wanted to be a series that was
filled with portraits that are somewhat
unexpected from latin america and from
los angeles filmmakers of latino latino
filmmakers the idea being that let's not
show the films that kind of perpetuate
the stereotype let's show the new vision
let's show an alternate vision
let's show something that's a little
surprising she of course is exactly that
a very surprising very full of life very
perceptive filmmaker she's been
nominated for an Oscar for her work in
documentary features and she is a
tireless advocate for the idea of
telling alternative stories please
welcome our curator Florida support to
you
thank you so much and I'm so happy to
see almost well I can't see that well
but it looks like a almost full house
it's pretty full first of all I want to
say that I'm deeply grateful to the
Academy for having invited me to curate
together with Ellen Harrington a series
of oral histories with Latin American
directors producers and screenwriters
that contributes to an unprecedented
archive for public access and scholarly
inquiry about Latinos in film this
project involved the participation of
nearly 50 members of the Academy's
professional staff across departments
and now I would like to begin by
acknowledging their contribution to this
effort in particular today right now I'd
like to thank Randy haver come he is the
he's the head of the Academy Foundation
and thanks to him we have this so these
oral histories are the beginning of a
cinematic resource that truly represents
and mirrors a multicultural in the
nation our selection of films connects
to the filmmakers who participated in
our oral history project and reflects a
time period in Latin America and Los
Angeles from 1967 to 2006 along with
their oral histories these artist films
reflect the new direction and production
that engages literature history and open
sexuality for the first time women
filmmakers are represented and might do
something wrong you see it says the
woman always blames herself
and it wasn't my fault for the first
time women filmmakers a representative
represented in significant numbers and
thematically they're more daring than
ever
I appreciate the profound 'ti of this
approach in the view of a general
absence of latina oral histories
subjects rather than doing for functor
ii interviews with familiar stories and
remaining on the surface this project
demands digging deeper it's deeper in
the sense of the directors producers and
writers participated in the long-form
oral history of up to five hours it took
the form of a thoughtful engaged
conversation not an interrogation such
an approach inevitably unearthing is
unexpected but deeply felt subjects that
influenced their lives and help them
become who they are for me it was an
enormous pleasure to take what I've
learned over the years in documentary
filmmaking and refine it deepening the
notion of what it is to interview what
it means to ask personal questions to
look for sincerity to look for instance
yeah to look for inspiration for dreams
for beauty and storytelling to recount
memories and to adapt him to once work
it was equally gratifying to see the
love of storytelling and construction of
language so I'm hoping that you like me
can relish these enormously compelling
characters and all and allow yourself to
dream of what will be their next
cinematic creation in the meantime this
offer has been initiated by the Getty
foundation with Pacific Standard Time la
la for which we offer our heartfelt
thanks I have to take a breath reading
is hard
histories that help us understand the
creative mind and what influences were
at play when they made their films all
these oral histories the book the you
know it's all available online so you
can see that if you go to our website we
are so pleased that you're here this
afternoon to hear the conversations we
have planned between filmmakers and in
this effort to rectify Latino absence on
the screen I feel that it is now the
moment to embrace this important step
and gesture of commitment on the part of
the Academy and supporting
well California will soon have a
majority Latino population Latinos and
behind behind the screen behind the
camera have been mostly absent to the
invention of cinema really consequently
there's a lot of work to be done I
reiterate that we as Latinos are also
part of the United States as well as
Latin America and we're glad that you
are here to see the work that we have
created together I would like to
introduce her host tonight for the panel
which will be Benji Griego she's a
producer and we're honored that she flew
from her home in Madrid to host this
woman's panel thank you so much for
assent
Thank You Luis
I want to welcome and thank you for
coming tonight and I want to thank the
Academy for hosting this symposium and
creating a space where we can honestly
safely without censorship discuss our
experiences when I was asked to host a
symposium titled
how do Latinas experience Hollywood my
first reaction was we don't and
certainly not proportionally or in a way
that is truly reflective of our
population within Hollywood Los Angeles
nationally or internationally both as
audiences audience members and talent
however you don't make progress or
create change with a knee-jerk reactions
we need to be willing to delve deeper
and to ask the question of why and more
importantly what do we want to see what
will it look like when we actually
finally get the
what will it take for there to be a
substantial shift in the paradigm of how
how business has been traditionally done
in Hollywood when it comes to telling
the stories of Latinos minorities people
of color but we also need to realize
that this is an ongoing discussion in an
ongoing education and sometimes an
ongoing battle these are not new
questions that people haven't tried to
crack before or that one can be answered
or they can be answered in one symposium
and one evening we need to continue to
dig deep and explore the answers we must
it is our responsibility as members of
the filmmaking community who have broken
through some of those barriers and
reached a certain level of success and
though certainly not without
difficulties or challenges but in the
end we have been able to tell our
stories as is clearly evident by the
many many credits and awards that these
incredibly talented women will have who
are our panelists this evening and yet
we can never be too satisfied there is
yet much to do and for that reason one
of the obvious observations is how how
we need to grow our role and
participation in the Hollywood power
structure until we have that proverbial
seat at the table
where the discussions that where the
discussions are had that influences and
decide which projects get green-lighted
which talent gets cast who gets hired
and whose stories are going to be told
and by whom it will be business as usual
and Latinos will continue to buy tickets
to the films where they don't see
themselves depicted in an honest
accurate or truly reflective way of it
there were truly reflective of the
complicated lives they lead we know we
have talent without a doubt you'll see
that tonight we know we have stories and
often others have told our stories with
great success for themselves so how do
we go from being a voice shouting from
the outside to being a descent to be to
being the decision-makers on the inside
again my hope is that our panel tonight
will share their insights about how they
have found their place within the
Hollywood structure or not not everybody
wants to work within Hollywood there are
other parallel viable options and we
hope to explore some of that as well
how
whether you're working within the system
or as an independent person within the
United States it is usually the
Hollywood model the bankable talent the
audience share etc that often dictates
how and what films will be made with our
panels we'll have the chance to discuss
what would have been the influences and
inspirations that have fed their
successes was it the support of mentors
strong peer network sheer grit and
stamina whatever the answer is for their
success we must harness and we must
learn from it so doing we can ensure
that the next generation has even more
success in that that proverbial table
becomes very very crowded we have to ask
what are our individual responsibilities
and at the same time we need to hold
what do we need to do to hold Hollywood
accountable especially when they
showcase in law diversity and yet the
reality is that there is little
reflection of african-americans and even
less of Asians Native Americans and
Latinos in the films and the television
programs that they were produced year
after year and like I said this is not
an issue that we're going to resolve
tonight or with one symposium but as we
but as we celebrate and honor the
collective ganas that is represented
today among our panelists the issues
these issues and these questions cannot
be forgotten so now I'd like to go ahead
and queue up the first clip to start our
first panel
la primera called película Colombian
acavie Chitina into 9 into 9 yo yo me
acuerdo Wow Mia
so miss with masks IDs so unless Casa
della radio porque what Italian island
video is son las personas que conozco
phone impact - muy grande por que
generic on siente que no está un de mis
professi mohini's put tan edit and
grundel influence okay quando chega can
be the star soon is dopin Sacagawea
Camuto a los demás
put your pins are no put your
crecimiento Hawai Cinco salary in los
angeles de charlie
it has caused a Sentosa Co Mary was seen
you know nunca for local siente que
pensar Akina differente me acuerdo cami
primer año y está una fiesta in in y
este hombre Grande premiere a fee on
Oprah do maybe less tent a los demás
co-sleep ellos newest crew member is
think if we found a lady affair for
campeón de mucho connects a perception
[Music]
I speak in caller who farted
if the murderer whether they were
followed really
[Music]
please don't waste the distilled water
it's expensive it's so hot in here
seriously I feel like I'm in hell
[Music]
6 how many more dresses to finish
Estella 18 only 18 such a relief is done
with this I know what are you do come on
it's so hard all the steam has been
sweating like a pig but we're sweating
don't but we're not thinking that
clothes off why not we're all women mom
we all have the same things I know
Estella roasted Lee Pancho please
aren't you hot in those clothes I feel
so sticky
aren't you embarrassed of what look at
you you look awful mama I happen to like
myself right on sister he do that two of
you should lose weight you would look
beautiful without all that fat
Dona Carmen I know they still are
beautiful they look good the way they
are Thank You Pancho Thank You Pancho
aren't you ashamed my MA you look just
like us yes but I married oh so that's
it make myself attractive so that I can
catch a man listen to her learn now or
you'll end up like a Stella
ma ma I do want to lose weight the part
of me doesn't because my weight says to
everybody they don't get booked how dare
anybody tell you something rice you look
like or what I should be then there's so
much more to me than just my weight
what's wrong with wanting to be thin and
sexy Rosalie
you don't get it well I want to be taken
seriously respected for what I think not
for how I look exactly thank you what if
you don't think anything I'd Rosalie I
look like a cop Rosalie shut up don't
look at yourself
if you're a cow then I'm a hippo and I'm
an elephant huh I know Morka I Rosalie
you are so skinny in comparison to all
of us you know I'm not look at my fat
hips and my cellulite you want to see
cellulite all right here we go
you start
[Music]
excuse me ladies it's Bella this is
Sally but you don't understand I got all
these stretch marks in my arms and
Gigi's small stretch marks can stretch
marks ago from North fresh beautiful we
are what we look like when no one's
watching
and I understand that we have parties
see on the audience so we'd like to
acknowledge but the reason for this
wonderful piece of work we're gonna get
our first panel started and I just want
to announce that we have two surprises
for our panel the first is kate del
Castillo an actress who's joining us
tonight
and second is carla salsa also an
actress and producer will be joining us
tonight so at this time I would at this
time I'd like to invite kate del
Castillo to come on up join me these are
on next I'd like to invite Amy Garcia to
come up and join us also an actress
[Applause]
in carlos salsa actress and producer
please come and join us we have carbon
kuba a casting director please come and
join us
[Applause]
Andy Vegas so we're gonna lead into this
first panels of discussion about image
and inspiration and as but 3c as film
just showed us one of my favorite clips
and I was looking as I was watching that
clip and thinking when we take ownership
of how we are presented it feels so
great and so empowering and there's just
such a great scene of these these women
and just and how she depicted these
images and I'd like to throw it out at
all of you and to think about this and
how how again going back to the idea of
the inspirations and images how does one
maintain your inspiration for your your
work whether your your work that you're
doing or have done or initially getting
involved and I want to start out with
the actresses and then we'll have a
couple of questions going this way but
we'll start out with with your as an
actress your inspiration maybe because
of images that you solve yourself or
didn't see as we know when when the
images are positive how it affects us
when images are negative or when we
don't see ourselves and I think that
that's that's a big a big big issue and
then we're trying to address and and
talk about so would either any of you
ladies like to who like to start first
well first first of all I'm very excited
to be here with his amazing ladies and
and you know I think one of the things
that has happened that happened to me
here in the United States I've been here
for a long time now but it's exactly not
to sexualize our our characters as
actors I think actresses I think we need
to to take care of them because
especially being a Latina there's so
many stereotypes still so all the time
and it just happened to me in in a movie
I had to be on my panties and walking
and I'm I was playing a lesbian but
hippy something like that right so but
the director thank God was it was a was
a woman and I but but the the the the
camera guy had he's the camera right on
my ass and and he said the cooler shot
no like like that so and it was funny
that the way they stood director was
like this is not what it is about the
movie she happens to be like that but
that's not what I'm trying to say so you
have a really nice cool you know with a
woman and I've worked with a couple of
women directors and it's totally
different you feel much much better and
and here in the United States it's just
not this it's not not sexualizing our
characters but also it's like okay so
latina I'm so mexicana pero so diferente
Jennifer Lopez she has he has another
character trying it because she comes
from Puerto Rico and and we come from
Mexico and we are not the same right so
there's a lot of things that we we need
I think we need a lot of work still to
do but what we're getting there thank
you well for me read um what I know was
a huge inspiration for me I remember
specifically reading an article in
latina magazine and reading that she was
one of the few people not just women to
win an Oscar atonia cramming an Emmy and
I didn't know that that was possible
because I was the first person in my
family
to ever be in entertainment and that was
a big change for me where I thought I'm
half Puerto Rican half Mexican I thought
she's Bodhi cause she's Puerto Rican and
she if she can do it I can do it and so
that was very influential for me and and
- you know Kate's point I am a little
bit more optimistic i i i do feel like
like we have a long way to go and but i
also i mean i i've been very fortunate
in playing professional Latinas and most
of my roles and a specific story I
remember I was doing Robocop with Jose
Padilla who's an incredible director did
elite squad Brazilian director and it
was a hundred million dollar budget
movie with Gary Oldman and Michael
Keaton and Sam Jackson and the scientist
was written Asian and I remember going
into casting and thinking well all right
I've told my team I said why can't I let
thee not be a scientist and they're like
well you know it's written Asian and I
said no I know it's our in Asian but I
have three degrees from Northwestern
you know I majored in economics
journalism and friends and and my mom
you know was the first Athena to
graduate Northwestern's dental school
and she's an orthodontist and so for me
I feel like I can play a scientist
easier than a lot of other things and
they push to get me in and they changed
the role and so I feel like it wasn't
even in their mind to think of Latinas
as molecular biologists and engineers
and and I think that yeah that has to
change and so for me I'm very inspired
by content creators because I think that
that's really where you make the baller
move right with with Gloria from once
one day at a time I think we have to
just kind of keep creating our own
content but I do think it's changing I
mean you play a you know a law student
professional and she was not initially
latina though so she wasn't yeah okay
yeah so do we want to segue there yeah I
was it's very similar to what she said I
went in the character's name
for the show how to get away with murder
and the character's name was Laurel
Wilding and I wasn't getting any of the
Latina parts when I when I first arrived
here it was three months into pilot
season and I walked into the Shonda
Rhimes Linda Lowry casting agency and it
was supposed to be just you know
whatever race and when I got the part
then they decided they wanted to make
her latina and they asked me and I said
no please and they asked me why I said
no please and I said because you're
gonna have me speaking like this and be
all sexual and you're out I was like I
don't I don't know I can't do that I
can't give you that
and so they said no no that's exactly
what we don't want to do and I said okay
but is there a Latin writer because it
all starts on the page because if not
they're gonna write what they're trying
so hard to not write is to not write a
stereotypes however they're so little
that they know of the culture there's
only so much they can know so I fought
really hard to have people like Daniel
sriracha who's now off doing her own
show and yeah different writers fit on
that quote Bale who have become each
season and I really stand up for having
them on the piece of paper having the
the Latinas or Latinos right for us
because I think that changes everything
and I think casting directors have so
much power to change that vision of a
director and say hey you know this
person can actually bring so much more
and become a you know a scientist or
let's even change the gender of the role
and just write it as I've done that to
where I'm like hey I think this would be
a great female role they're like what
and I said you don't have to change
anything of the role just make it female
and I recently worked with Catalina I
he'll add on everybody loves somebody
and I had the same culo shot experience
where I had just recently done another
movie where you know the camera does the
pan and I had to be running on the beach
and it was slow-motion I had done so
much dieting for that I was like oh no
and then I'm on this new film with
Catalina he'll add and and I'm sort of
waiting for the cooler shot and I'm like
so when are we doing the cooler you know
the body shot
she's like no we're staying you know
this is where it's happening
I was like they just started crying I
was like so I can go and have that bus
stayed over there I could go out she was
like yeah no we don't need that and
she'd let me wear this really ugly
lingerie because that's what I you know
thought the character would wear and
when I had sweat marks which I probably
have today sorry about that
she let me have a with him they wouldn't
come in running to make sure I wasn't I
was a I was allowed to be real and so
that was a blessing and of course it was
a blessing to work with female director
for the first time which is ridiculous
but yeah well I think that's one of the
things you were hearing in common here
is this the idea of the female director
which hasn't been very common in the
last 10-15 years and also what I'm
hearing is that women are not only are
you participating and what in the image
of how you're going to be portrayed but
you're actually being huge advocates for
how that image is going to be created
and and advocating for writers I don't I
don't really remember having
conversations with folks where actresses
felt empowered to have that kind of a
conversation and to insist unless they
were you know financing or you know so
how I'm curious to know how how that
transpired and how you were able to
I didn't ask that's the thing that's the
thing I didn't ask and a lot of my
co-workers were like you said what and I
was like well yeah I mean because I come
from luckily I've been producing things
in Mexico where I have a say in the
casting or I have a say in the story in
the script and so suddenly I came to
here and I thought well it's to say you
know same thing like I the more I put my
heart and everything the wardrobe
everything so I said well this is what
I'll give you I don't just give you you
know the acting side of me I'll give you
like a lot of my opinion on storyline
and everything and so I feel it's just
about coming from an empowered place
rather than asking for permission and if
you have good ideas they're gonna listen
to you because they're sometimes they're
running out of those ideas and they
really want that fresh way to look at it
yeah like I'm playing a scientist now
and Lucifer and they mentioned you know
I believe in one thing and I said you
know what let's talk about the brothers
and
and where she's from in Detroit and I
don't even ask to speak Spanish like
when whenever I talk to my mom I just
always speak Spanish so I'll I'll just
do it on and off like if my brother is
calling I'll be like que pasa and and
they they love it
so I think you're right and and I
remember even people are very affected
by what they see and and like on Dexter
I was running around in a bikini most of
the time I said every time she's on the
phone with Dexter she's gonna be
studying because she's a psychology
student so I didn't ask I went to props
I'm like look I want textbooks
I want pens I want pads and and then
when we blocked it it was already there
and I was in my bikini you know showing
a little culo I'm like sister be
stunning so you do you little by little
girl that's what we're talking about
[Laughter]
well I want to segue over to you Carmen
and working as a casting director and
and listening to what they're talking
about and thinking about you the
trajectory of your career and what
you've experienced and is this
conversation that you're hearing here
something that is the norm how what's
what is this stuff what has this been
started to change and shift it that
these women can feel empowered to make
these kinds of demands well all I could
think of is that there are no cool Oh
shots in my job really grateful for that
distracted by that sorry no I mean I
think it must be the norm but I will say
that in mice I don't want to say circle
in in sort of my peer group or my may
even just my close friends it doesn't it
does feel like the norm because we are
all very empowered we all come from a
place of believing that we can get what
we want and be heard so and that's how
I've come up you know when I this whole
thing how do Latinas experience
Hollywood has been like driving me crazy
because I've think been thinking about
it and it's just for me and I think it
probably is for a lot of us it's such a
it feels so long like a independent
journey that that were not experienced
like what you said at the beginning that
we're not Experian
and seeing it we're just experiencing
our own sort of survival and our own
project a project and making those
decisions and for me so much of it I
mean let's face it all of us have have
times in our career where you're just
lucky people are offering you something
so you're saying yes but for me when I
look back at it it's about the voices
that I can help empower right so it's
like making changing a character from
white latina or female male to female or
or supporting filmmakers who have
diversity of thought I think that for me
is very important and I have a I think I
have a unique experience because I guess
because I'm ethnically ambiguous is the
word and so I've been able to I don't
have a lot of conversations in my super
mainstream I work with Ridley Scott I
work with Steven Soderbergh who that
part of me doesn't come up in a very
direct way but when I'm talking about
changing apart I I know that they listen
in a different way because they don't
know how I'm gonna react and if they say
no you know I have I have had a an
important director when I brought
something up you know when I said you
know we really have to be careful about
which way we go at this part it was a
part of a Mexican and it was actually a
whole it hasn't been done yet but a
whole movie that takes place in Mexico
with Mexicans and he was like well shoot
it in Spain and I'm like all right but
we're gonna have to take some things
into consideration he's like is that
really a thing yeah and he was like okay
great and then he listened they listened
so you know I don't know exactly this
whole my experience in the broader
spectrum of it but my personal
experience has just been I'm Who I am I
come from a super diverse background I
didn't only grow up here like
none of us really only grew up here and
and I'm gonna push for the world's to
look like what my world looks like and
what it didn't look like for me when I
moved here when I was 11 mm-hm
you know for me it was Connie Chung like
that was my I was gonna be Connie Chung
then Oprah came along so you know but I
and I knew anyway we could talk more
about this other stuff but yes that's my
answer to that and I want to now go on
to Yvette and I had this we've talked a
little bit earlier about some of the
things that the work that you do with
the national media coalition hasn't just
back media coalition and from the point
of view repair oh yeah I'm really give
it up for them and the National Hispanic
media coalition who advocates for the
Latino images and images and
participation and what kind of evolution
and growth have you witnessed and for
the years that you've been working with
within this realm nowhere near enough
and I I'm coming at you from a
completely different place so I love it
because they're they're actresses and
casting director and I am in marketing
and PR and prior to starting my own
company 20 years ago I was an executive
in the studio system and also in the
record industry where I was one of the
only brown people in the room but I'm
from New Jersey and I speak English like
this and so you know I didn't know that
there was something so special about me
until the fact that I kept kept getting
called in to meetings because people
wanted my opinion and I thought really
Jersey girl ac/dc Led Zeppelin okay so
it was the skin you know the color of my
skin and after that kept happening over
and over again throughout my career I
was lucky enough to have an incredible
mentor who taught me everything and made
me a strong independent woman and I
absolutely adore her for that and when I
got to Hollywood twenty-something years
ago I you know unfortunately I think
that we have a long way to go I don't
think there's anywhere near enough
change I'm I'm in the studio sorry of it
so I get to deal with the networks and
the studios and i'm you know exposed to
the people that are making these
decisions right and and so what I think
has changed is is we have changed we're
no longer gonna take it and so we're
gonna be strong we have to come together
we can't be Puerto Rican and Mexican and
this and that because they don't look at
you as you they don't see that all they
see is brown so I think what's changed
is that we must come together as a
community and we must you know we must
take our place and we can no longer be
nice and apologize and ask very nice you
know we just really need to come
together is that I think that's the
change I see in my community of people
you know the people were just done we're
ready we're ready to take it to them I
didn't even know that I was brown I yeah
I was white all my life yeah until I got
here I knew that now I'm brown now we're
that so I said okay I'm brown really
wait what no your brownie Arwen yes well
I also think that I'm you know we're
talking about the 80s and the 90s you
know we're talking about you know I
actually I grew I was born in Puerto
Rico but I got here at 3 so I really you
know I grew up here I'm an American I
mean we're all Americans I'm not saying
but so I really Diane brown so I does I
mean yes and I completely understand
where you're coming from because I have
kids that aren't brown but they're
Latinas right so so we're all Latinos
but unfortunately or fortunately you
know you are looked at differently for
the color of your skin and you can pass
until you open your mouth then you have
an accent all right all right
and those things happen well thank you
ladies and now because we have such
there's such a short time I only have 20
minutes per per group so we have to
segue to our next panel
we're gonna have some time if I keep it
moving we'll have a little bit we'll
have some time at the end for some
questions so we can revisit so we're
gonna go on to our next video clip and
that'll influence our next panel and
ladies you stay up here with me and then
the next group will just join us we'll
continue to grow and by the end of the
day we're gonna have an entire studio
created up here
mama we participate Asia souvenirs
represent our own so when you're really
sad can you at exactamente assert seen a
better see they are said I'll go come on
to be si fuera del standard the de lope
de la cosa posible para ser o una mujer
en sultana llamo say la carrera que
neuronal men Thema SEL upon heard him
Salta present a big mama siempre key so
he to nominee de sahin fan Tilly Fantasy
OSA que tener una vida extraordinary ax
y quiero una manera que mi vida no
extraordinary s imagine Oso para me para
me n sin who muna constructio no say so
de pensamiento y yo no creo que el
pensamiento esta xn toda motion no no I
shall go freely Hannah Mucha gente me
película son free up okay now música no
no no no no veo el su free me ento a
romantic Oh que tienen algunas otras
película pro bono es es otra cosa pero
si lo que creo que la película zone un
proceso de pensamiento donde durante una
todo sobre holy media uno compartir con
el expected or no no tanto uni torial
sino como una forma en que se construes
en la cosa
just don't look somebody giggles OH
autonomy porque la marseillaise' Paris
in Astana sloshes no I did
[Music]
[Music]
one thing I was aware
[Music]
get over Saturday forget our ceremonial
[Music]
decision
[Music]
nobody sanitizer hola mami and the play
laughter Harvey
[Music]
so monitoring go they silicone parasha
mahaprabhu just angry
mommy and daddy with helical ponies
under color they failure make it easier
Alessia naga
there we go and now I'd like to and okay
just right one more time
and now I'd like to invite the next
group of panelists up and we're gonna
start with Natalia Almada
director how do I give it all a director
Patricia vegan Leslie said we can and go
buddy let's ivv on nadia vini i
practiced that so many times
[Applause]
thank you ladies for joining us and here
are all the action here the directors
the actresses female oh here we go we're
getting to that studio here that's right
a few of them well I want to start out
with the policia talks about how he's
trying to be in the process the about
films be in a process of thought and
where you share with the audience the
art of constructing a story when you're
approaching your store hello
so when you're approaching your story to
tell how do you approach the audience in
that process we talked about your your
processes your artistic process your but
also but but in response to what she's
talking about a half sheet of all the
audience and things of the audience but
this yeah you want to start with that
yes
thinking about your audience me yes hi
I love the audience I love the audience
and the way I approach so I do think
about the audience but the way I
approach is approach it is that I am the
audience so I am the measure of
everything you know if I feel if it
makes me think if it makes me cry you
know whatever it is I'm the audience so
the key is to have that very special
skill that every now and then I lose
what I normally have which is to watch
what I do for the first time every
single time I watch it you know so
that's that's with the big key you know
to be able to sit down and become an
audience member and not guess what's
happening that's the hard part
so what's that the question you ask
talking about the audience I mean the
consideration of the audience when you
make your films and how you how you see
your your audience getting involved with
your film and Natalia can we pick up
both with you on that and how you did
your creative process and how the
audience becomes involved with that sure
I think I'm probably the wrong person to
answer that question I don't think too
much about the audience and which is why
I'm asking it's for many things I think
it's a question that's often asked when
you come from the periphery in a sense
that's who's your audience and it's a
loaded question that's often code for
I'm not your audience so who's your
audience right I don't speak Spanish so
I have to read subtitles Oh who's your
audience so that kind of makes me feel a
little bit of verse and I also find that
one of the most rewarding things about
my filmmaking career has been showing my
films to such different audiences right
so high school students in LA or we were
just in South Korea or all these
different places and you say well who's
your audience well all those different
things different people and what's
interesting is to see how do they
connect differently and what do they
understand in the film and that's
rewarding for me so I hate to think of
this kind of limiting
concept of pinpointing a demographic as
an audience I think there's a different
way of thinking about it and what I like
about what Lucretia says is that she's
less interested in the story as she is
in the structure of a story so how we
tell our stories is often what reflects
who we are and where we're from
not just the whole concept that you have
to have this plot that unfolds in a
certain way and has a certain kind of
ending is a cultural concept right so
when we tell our stories we have to be
able to structure them as we think not
as others think thank you and Otto and
as you're pro as you were starting up a
new story or new project
what is your creative process and what
are the kinds of things that you are
that are influencing how you begin to
look at a project or look at a film
subjects yeah well I think I'm
influenced by two things one is what
I've lived and experienced first and
foremost because that's one of the big
reasons why I started to do this and get
involved in this is that I I wasn't I
wasn't connecting to most the stories or
I felt myself forcing myself to connect
because there was nothing else that
really resonated with me so I definitely
start with personal and I feel like my
although my experience is specific I do
feel like that there are a lot of people
out there that could connect to what I
have to say especially because it it
hasn't been reflected so I do start
there and then I'm definitely impacted
by what's happening in the world
so my creativity is constantly like this
is like I'm always like
because the world is so you know crazy
all the time you know prior to Trump
Trump and probably post so there's a lot
that is you know making me want to put
pen to paper or finger to keyboard and
and then and then as the story starts to
come about if I don't particularly
belong to a group that I'm writing about
saying documented people because I'm I'm
a citizen so I have that privilege then
I think about how do I connect with the
undocumented community to try to try to
have a dialogue very early on where you
know I'm I'm I'm in conversation with
them about the stories that I'm thinking
about and and seeing how they're feeling
about it or or what's the story that
they want to see reflected and then we
start to talk about well you know how
else can this process of making this
film support whatever work the
undocumented community is doing so I'm
like I'm very early on talking to
communities that I'm a part of or I want
to be in conversation with and so that's
very early on all the way through and it
informs the work so I'm so they are a
part of my audience so I am thinking of
audience but I'm not so much I don't
think I'm writing for them necessarily
it's it's a there's an organic process
that I engage in where I feel like I
have to honor my my writing spirit my
creative spirit but I'm also thinking
about what I want to say politically you
know and hoping that what I want to say
is smart so that's that's that's part of
my process and Gabriela can you talk to
us about your process your creative
process well I'm a Latina and a woman so
I try to make the movies that I want to
see and I try to convince the other
people to make those movies I have one
of my best friends calls me the ball so
when I go too far
Studios for example I say I wanna make
Marilyn Monroe movie but with three
Latinas and so I pitched that and I I
sold it all so for example I have
another project with David permit who's
a producer who is nominated for many
Academy Awards and he is a story about
two girls right two young women and I go
what David how about is one of them is
latina and he goes well I don't know any
do you know so I go with my nerd list of
here's Carla she's represented but W me
her list of so I just go and educate the
people that don't know and of course
they can't say no because I'm latina
again like otherwise they'd be races
right so I kind of like use that and
also can't put Latinas enrolled not
necessarily Latinas for example I have a
project and the producer is here and he
can tell you he's Korean he wand can for
for a movie and I have a project that
he's how about learners I mean Chan the
Mona Lisa and I go why can't the Mona
Lisa be a Latina you know so I showed
him all the pictures of Anna Lilla
ruggero sitting next to him and go the
three of them could be Ivana Lisa yeah
also I think that I to answer your
question I make the movies I want to
make and you just bend bend the rules
and if we think of latina directors as
the boo in front of all the Matadors you
know the bull comes out he has no chance
there's like 10 guys with swords but
once in a while the Bulls kills the
matador
[Applause]
I find it funny that you asked us about
the audience because the question is how
do we get a job you know that's for me
always in my head and I'm sure it's all
of us it's our daily fight our entire
beings are devoted to getting a job like
to fighting it and then once you get it
to survive in it because even if you get
it they're gonna make your life
impossible throughout from the first
minute to the last you know so I was
like prepared to talk about that and
then the artists ever hey taking them on
the journey well talk about that
actually one of the segue right into
working within the studio system and
without the studio system so like I said
earlier not everybody wants to be a not
everybody's journey is directly or their
mission is to work in Hollywood and we
were taught was talking earlier with
with Natalia and we were talking about
how oftentimes your your your your
trajectory goes from sundance film
festival getting accolades and then you
get into hollywood it's just like this
this natural path but not everybody is
on that natural path or wants that
natural path and so I think of what
you're talking about here is you know
you're looking for work so we're you're
looking for work all the time constantly
within the studio system without the
studio
what's your choices I feel that I have
lost my voice in the last few years in
the search of career you know of looking
for the job and I you know I feel like I
need to create a number of movies or
shows or whatever to create a name so
that then I can go back to do my stuff
you know so that's kind of where I am
and I've been thinking about the Latina
and the woman experience before coming
here as I was driving and the problem is
being a woman not being a Latina
that's the
the main main main problem that we all
here have I think and it's very clear
you know it's very very clear as you all
I never realized that I was a woman de
who realize that I am a woman okay so I
feel like I have been using the Latina
because okay latina I don't think it's a
problem anymore because there are like
three mega Mexican amigos that create it
open up this this space for Latinos to
come and direct space movies and Harry
Potter movies and stuff so I feel that
thank god those guys kind of did a
service to all Latinos now on this you
know we cannot access that kind of
project the problem is being a woman so
what I've been doing lately is using the
Latina angle to get the job that would
be for a man so I can get it so that's
how I'm getting jobs that let's say the
33 which was meant to be directed by a
man because it's 33 miners with drills
and stuff like that
or you know I did you know I'm doing a
show right now that it's also like a
thriller horror should be for a man but
he has a Mexican angle so that's how I
insert myself in those in those jobs
using the Latina
to my advantage is like you know if
you're not Mexican you're never gonna
understand the subject matter you know
you kind of say that kind of thing and
you say it and say it so many times that
they're like okay we can not hire you
know a New York Jew you know to direct a
movie about the Latino experience and so
I'm one of the Latinas Latinos so that's
how I'm getting it so anyway I'm trying
to see the advantages okay
we have to work every angle because it's
not none of it's easy right well I will
reach out to get to the makers here and
to talk to you guys and ask you about
the responsibilities that you might feel
to actually take on to tell the stories
about your culture their cultural
background or to move without to move
outside of it like you were saying the
Latinos telling stories about Harry
Potter and
and they're not taught we're not talking
about you know immigration stories we're
not talking about you know the nautical
stories they're they're talking about
something they're able to make to do and
it tells other types of stories but as
filmmakers and at this point in your
career in life is there a sense of
responsibility that you want it tell the
stories that are about your cultural
backgrounds or at least infuse your
stories with this with your cultural
background take that one
I hate when they send me these projects
that are like Latino and there's like a
Latino family and there's every time
there's no story you know and sometimes
it's not even written by a Latino it's
kind of like oh they Mexican curious
kind of story and I was like I prepare
go the other way around have a good
story that either I right or somebody
writes and then put Latino actors and
actresses in it and as I said they don't
have to be necessarily a Latino
character it could be an Italian
character why can't like they were
saying why can't a Latina be a scientist
or anything so I just go more for the
story and then I make it my own
by casting it the way I want it and of
course it's a responsibility and it's a
responsibility about the message for me
is very important that's why I wouldn't
I won't do movies about regret or
revenge to me is not a novel feeling I
rather do movies about love and positive
messages that hopefully elevate the
world so that I'd rather do a script
that is not that great but it has a good
message and then I work in making it
better thank you
does anybody want to comment on that or
say anything because if not I have yeah
yeah no I I mean I I've I definitely
feel a responsibility I mean I I come
for I was born here come from
working-class background my parents are
immigrants you know struggled a lot you
know daily fighting I've experienced you
know all the isms here and and I feel
like it's it's kind of a luxury to not
tell stories that are political or have
some social commentary or wanna shift
culture and want to say something I
don't feel like I came into this for
that you know I came into this wanting
to shift things wanting to change things
wanting to empower us wanting to do all
of that and it's not the easy road you
know it's not it's not easy people don't
want to produce your [ __ ] people don't
want to you know it's real you're angry
[Laughter]
I'm totally good with it but um but yeah
I mean it continues to motivate me when
we don't see people of color in front of
you know on screen we don't see them
behind the camera we don't we just don't
get that at all so I want to tell those
stories and I want those complex stories
you know I don't want that just just
because they're you know it's they have
a brown cast that I want to do it like
it has to be smart you know what I mean
like I just I'm not here to do the
Paycheck the Paycheck is good I'm not
gonna lie like of course I have a family
but but I came into this for those
reasons that it is what drives me and
fuels me and so you know so I I feel
like I'm not alone there's there are
many filmmakers that feel that that may
be a responsibility maybe is not the
right word but they feel that those
ganas you know and that that drive and
that that reason why they're doing what
they're doing so so yeah so that's
that's what I'm trying to do you
and go ahead I'm saying about this
struggle that it's just kind of a
through frustrating you know that that
i-i've been an actress since I was nine
and and then I still think that I'm
struggling you know so I'm a struggling
actress still because I still don't get
the job that I want and sometimes as she
said well I don't have a family but I do
have myself to to pay the bills you know
so I so sometimes you have to prostitute
yourself in that way and do things
sometimes that you don't really love or
commercials or this and that just
because you need to eat and and at least
I'm not selling quesadillas not saying
that that's wrong but I'm still doing my
craft what I love and what what I've
been doing my entire life so but it's
still strongly the entire time you know
and and and the actually the last two
movies that I've done well one was
because butBut Patricia is like one of
my best friends so she puts me in
everything she wants
now that is suspicious no but um the
other day it was supposed to be also an
American white woman and and they
changed it which which I think it's it's
awesome that they can think outside the
box
the not only our managers imprinted in
our team you know managers and and in
agents but also that the directors are
more open to and are more open to my
accent too
you know because it's always something
it's always or you are not to Mexican
why don't you you have your hair like
it's not black it's like well no isn't
that's not all we we have in Mexico no
we have also salons there
you know so so it's it's traveling the
entire time and it's kind of frustrating
but also do you know to be honest I said
she said is that the positive
positiveness of the whole thing is that
it keeps you working and keeps you
struggling and trying to and your life
is like this because I don't have it for
real I don't have nothing you know
they're solid and and that makes me wake
up every single day and say I have to
get out of here and go struggle and go
find a job responsibilities actually I
just wanted to talk about that because I
do feel like I have a responsibility I
live in the house that Robert Rodriguez
built Robert Rodriguez the Mexican
American filmmaker he was my client I
worked on all of his films so I have a
very good life thank you Robert I also
have a successful company that turned 20
so I thank you so I worked for the
studios and I've worked with great
filmmakers and actors etc etc and now my
company turned 20 I turned a certain
number and now I feel like I can no
longer I not that I did because I have a
big mouth if anybody knows me knows that
that's true but now i 100% feel
responsible to say what I have to say
when I have to say I don't work for a
studio I don't work for a network I
don't work for an agency nobody can fire
me and I'm and so right now I feel a
responsibility for out for us to see
ourselves reflected my children my
family for us to see ourselves reflected
in a multi-dimensional way on television
and film but not only just to inspire my
community a Latino community but what
happened last year is Hollywood and the
media must take a little bit of
responsibility okay so and so that's why
I'm fired up because people know people
are uncomfortable seeing people that are
different so when you watch television
and you watch films that's where you
learn right that's where you're
entertained but you learn about things
about people and about different
communities and so for me my
responsibility is to talk to my friends
and Hollywood producers director
executives and explained to them in the
nicest way possible that they have a
really big responsibility
they really do cuz I mean we're you know
our country is this is a very very very
what's the word I'm looking for because
I shouldn't occurs this is a very
difficult time in our country I feel
like the media and Hollywood absolutely
100% can make a difference and bringing
this community this country together and
that's by what they put on the big and
small screen absolutely I think also I
think it starts I remember there was you
know there's a way for all of us to
connect with other people every time I
see an amazing latin-american movie I
send it to
WME and I say you have to see this
amazing Anna Christie Nevada and she's
an ecuadorian director she reminds me of
Luke Wright and my tailor Lynn Ramsay so
then they connect her and then suddenly
she can be directing something else or I
knows a via Dolan suddenly you know he's
in a he's in a festival in can and now
he's directing you know Hollywood a-list
actors and I feel like it's our
responsibility to share amazing work to
make Hollywood better and to therefore
also have all this diversity and even
even if it's in the smaller scale on a
TV show
I begged them to not put subtitles when
I speak Spanish because that says you
need to be speaking Spanish to people
when you're saying something in Spanish
and you're catering to that community
saying don't worry like this is this
doesn't need to be subtitled this is
something that's happening in the u.s. a
lot you should be able to know what
she's saying more or less I think it's
so powerful
and they did it for the first time I
think the third season and it wasn't
just like a mommy or papi it was like a
whole paragraph of Spanish and I know
that that's like a small level but
everything that we do all of us on this
panel really does make a difference
thank you and all of everyone else in
here and I've got my red light on over
here but I'm but I have one what I
really wanted to just kind of turn this
idea of responsibility around and kind
of flip it up on all of you ladies here
and we talk about responsibility for for
what we want to say but what's the
responsibility for the generation behind
us we all we have all struggled a lot
a lot of us have struggled when there
wasn't a lot there weren't the mentors
who are actually pulling us up or giving
us a support today you guys are we are
those mentors we are those ones who can
create a space for the younger
generation so in that in that vein and
that idea of the responsibility that we
all have how do you look at that and how
what do you do to fulfill that
responsibility if in fact you feel you
have that and I will start who you're
shaking your head so I'll start with
yeah no I mean that's how we're gonna
make change you know like I mean I I
still feel like a baby still coming up
and and I was really blessed that people
like Patricia Cardozo who is my active
mentor who opened up the door when she
made real women have curves I was
assisting her and she was super generous
like she she was one of the first people
that allowed me on set and I saw what
the power of mentorship because I
experienced it in terms of that
generosity of being like a Laura
whatever you want to learn a Kista like
just ask be there be present she was
never like hoarding or nervous or you
know like territorial like I've worked
hard to be here no she totally got it
and and I came into filmmaking inspired
by collectives of women of color that I
would read about and learn about and I
was in the youth movement in San
Francisco there was a lot of
collectivity and I understood that power
of being and community and that that is
power is being in community and not that
this individual person makes it and
represents us all that that's just it's
got to be we got to be done with that
right we need to we need to be as a
community present in this space and and
I also experienced that through Ava
Duvernay
who extended her hand and allowed me to
be a director on Queen sugar and she is
phenomenal
like just she's so intentional about
everything she does and I feel like
that's we have to be conscious about
what we're doing in every step however
we can do it mentorship can look it many
many different ways
and it can impact people many many
different ways but I am definitely
seeing it with my african-american
sisters the way they look out for each
other and they're extending their hand
to me too I'm like we need to do this
folks in our community and across
community you know building solidarity
with other communities and I think
Carla's point like you really do have a
lot of power it's such a small world and
you know you you don't have to be best
friends with you know Guillermo del Toro
to really make a difference you know in
your own small way you can really make
such a difference like I really think
you're affected by what you see and I
keep saying that and I'm involved in
this charity called most and I realized
that when these girls are watching TV
they never really saw a whole family of
Latinos but that was so personal but
also very universal so Justina Machado
and I who's she's a Chicago girl I've
known her forever
and she's like why don't we rent a bus
for these girls and bring them to a live
taping a Norman Lear's show and they can
meet Rita and Norman and and it was such
a small thing you know it's like renting
a bus for 80 girls or whatever and they
they spent six hours just watching
Justyna crush it and read them what I
know crush it and here's you know living
legend and Norman Lear another living
legend and they saw their stories and so
the five of them were like I want to
write TV I want to write stories and
it's just something so simple that if
they see it they can believe it but if
all they see is the guy who has the car
the guy who has you know the girl is
doing X Y & Z like it's it's such a I
think filmmaking movies TV are the most
empathetic form of storytelling and if
you make someone laugh you make someone
cry then they will listen and and to me
film and TV can like really change the
world you know so I think that it is a
big responsibility but every single
person especially now with social media
you have so much power and so I think of
instead of waiting for oh when this
happens I'll have the platform when that
happens like we have the platform
and you'd be surprised so
only definitely definitely feel
empowered and I think that the world is
finally catching up to thinking wow we
really want to see ourselves reflected
and now that the cats out of the bag
like the world is your oyster you don't
need a rent a red camera you can
literally shoot a movie on your iPhone
and win at Sundance and that's such a
cool thing you know so say you want to
say something in my red light a certain
hasn't started blinking but doesn't gone
off and yeah very quickly ignore for
just two more seconds two quick ones and
then we'll have to move on talking about
responsibility my biggest responsibility
is to be very good because if I fail
this everyone pays all that women behind
me around me and all the Latinas like we
are held to a standard that has nothing
to do with anything else so if a guy
messes up in a movie and it's a flop
you're not gonna say I'm never gonna
hire another man again to direct the
movie but if a woman fails we all pay so
my responsibility is to work so hard and
to be better than any time so that I can
open just keep opening the doors that's
what I do I suffer a lot I also think I
have a responsibility of not only
changing what's in front of the camera
but what's behind the camera because I
agree with Patricia that is very very
difficult more to be a woman director
than a Latino director so I now have a
TV show and I started getting the idea I
came up with a latina showrunner and I
was telling Patricia you know what if
the three directors in the show are
three Latina women it's about three
women why not so that's what I'm gonna
go Beach it you know I'm gonna go pitch
when I pitch the show and that's you
know because it starts with behind the
camera if we have latina writers latina
directors then it would be no question
of who's in front of the camera because
we're telling the stories that we want
and
it is I had a lot of racist stories I'm
just gonna tell one little one I was
directing a movie in Utah and it was the
first day of the shoot I I go to the
bathroom and this woman from accounting
come sir I'm so happy I'm directing
Sharon Stone I think I made it she's
amazing
as I said action already I go to the
bathroom and this woman from accounting
comes to me and says we have to change
please change the toilet paper I swear
to God true story and I said I'm the
[ __ ] director true story well on that
note we're gonna cure our next video
clip
yo creo que cuando yo LPN son los
noventa si si si
maybe años que no puede levantar ninguna
película de real in median can you start
off in management I seen community
metros con el pais increases economic
Asim fondos de Finance Ament cetera
realmente simmer then possibly dobkiss
impossible event are una película in Co
speedos mi vida pero ahora no es a see
or Anessa sino a pretext o see you no
quiero hacer Sununu o VAR y lo vas a
Armas un colectivo tes de la minima
tecnología yaran cos ya rank aziz o el
camino haciendo como como si psychomotor
minus y C tienes la Tennessee da Del Rio
or el talento lo vas a terminar la
diferencia de mujer verano era muy bien
OS corals defini dos ojos losses violent
O's Verdes aquas see ya Vida vida veces
y mira los crisis Lila's Plata's Megan
de lujan no Sara demasiado Pope ariados
Moya's
dynasty of Reseda buscando Strasse un
hombre a hula perez no Mesa algas
Canisius tienen do de Paris Earp you
today gusta la a los hombres da dat da
Mucha Pena dices que a las buscando a to
primo lentejas
I know huh I see hmm
[Music]
[Music]
see ya perdóname Padre inform our in
Quemoy esta el barco Borrego Parko
Griego como Sagayam el barco no sé pero
Mira Heron case el único brave okay
Martinez you scam el barco Griego purple
mist amigo opposite
por el momento no tenemos deformation
[Music]
[Applause]
sayidina Thoris and Monique arena I
[Applause]
think we really do have all the
components up here of a solid studio
[Laughter]
well this text this last panel section
of our three panels we wanted to talk
about the about impact and impact of the
filmmakers it can have and how they
could can manage and take charge of your
creative output I earlier I'm hesitant a
little because I had a conversation
earlier with Monica about the work that
she does in Mexico and the way she got
her start in film and with her desire to
to be in control of the images to be in
control of the kinds of projects he did
and the work that you did Monica can you
talk to us a little bit about how you
started out as a cinematographer studied
as a cinematographer and because you
didn't take away it's her story right
well yeah I I went to film school very
unknown film school until like you
mentioned other like people like Cologne
and Chivo started like winning Oscars
and all I wanted to do when I was in
film school was become a cinematographer
so when I left film school I was working
as a cinematographer in the 90s and I
would have right to the set and they're
like oh yeah I got a product or a
producer is here and I'm like no I'm the
cinematographer the DP and people were
like and everybody was scared they
gaffer the staff and how can this woman
is gonna tell me where to put the camera
the lights and he was like like that
every time
commercials anything that I was shooting
and this enraged me and one time I
remember I went home like arrive like
3:00 4:00 a.m. after like 24 hour shoot
and I was like I swear to myself one day
I will own my own company and I will
have the cameras to shoot whatever I
want whenever I want and it doesn't
matter if I'm Martian if I'm lesbian
whatever I am but a woman I don't need
to apologize to anybody and that's how I
started so 17 years ago I started my
company simplemente and we were
producing initially little documentaries
and TV shows and whatever we could with
like the cultural TV stations in Mexico
and then like life because I loved
camera so much and I love technology
kind of push me to learn more about
technology which filmmaking is beautiful
because you have the storytelling and
also you have the science of cameras and
and you know it's like a perfect melt so
I started helping people advising like
how to make your movies easier better
with less money and precisely what you
just said I mean we have now the
possibility to help filmmakers should
anything they want however they want
with the technology that it was
impossible like 20 years ago it was like
no way I mean when I was in film school
like we were shooting with 16 mil
each can was so valuable we had to think
we had to suffer every foot and now we
just have like you said like mobile
phones even but it's it's amazing times
and what we've been doing in Mexico is
trying to democratize the means of
production some more people that are
incredibly talented and creative can do
more stuff and of course it's impacting
like all the women in Mexico that we're
trying to make a difference and that's
like in a nutshell like my almost 20
years after I left film school that
great that's truly how you how you can
control your creative output and you
know when when they're making a
difficulty for it difficult way we just
got him create a company for yourself
thanks to Monica's company I was able to
make my first fiction feature film
because they provided all the cameras
editing equipment everything we needed
you know with no no questions asked not
like with your audience I just want to
add something because I consider myself
like a cheerleader of the projects will
help produce and I am so proud because
we just got like a quote from like the
most famous Mexican critic who told that
Natalia's movie is a masterpiece of
minimalist Mexican cinema and that made
me so proud and I'm so happy
[Applause]
and just quickly this isn't a question
with just a comment do you do
co-productions under your work you've
been working a lot in the co-production
field as well so I think that's also
something that we have to look at as we
are looking at you know how do Latinas
how are we how do we work within
Hollywood how do we how are we with in
Hollywood and and how can we make the
films that we want to make and it's not
always within this particular structure
and I think the co productions that
there's a lot of variety up here we
could have a whole other panel about
just that we wanted to talk about
earlier about co-productions but that's
something that's really important to
know about the the other thing i want
it's kind of an awkward segue but again
sort of keeping control of our vision
and keeping control of our stories and
what how we want to to talk about what
we want to talk about and and how to
protect our stories through the pipeline
and ehia I wanted to I wanted to send
this towards you and ask you about how
vigilant you've had to be as you've
shepherded projects with a pipeline to
make sure that your story stays intact
how that process has worked and and what
you've had to do to maintain that well I
mainly work within the studio system and
the network system so keeping that
vision intact is almost impossible and I
would even say that even when you're
working in an independent film there's a
lot of people with a voice about what
you what they think the movie should be
or what they think the television show
should be and so what what you try to do
is just do the best job that you
possibly can do in the job that you are
hired to do and whenever you can speak
out about something you do and whenever
you can't you realize that you're there
as a person who has just been hired to
do the job but there are times when you
can also be replaced I'm mainly a writer
and in the film world much more than in
television you can be replaced very
easily in the last two years I've
actually done five rewrites
another writer's work so there were
writers that were replaced by me so I
know that at any point I can be replaced
by another writer based on the work that
I do but I have had both experiences
actually I've had in the case of my
independent film la misma Luna which but
that he's directed it was a very
collaborative experience and I had a
very strong voice in where the end of
the script
ended and then there were other you know
the film that I did after that means my
Luna was a movie called firelight which
was for ABC and Hallmark Hall of Fame
and it was a story about women in prison
and how a firefighting program helped
them to have a skill so that they
wouldn't have to come back into the
prison system and it's based on a true
story 90% of the women that go through
that program don't come back to prison
versus the women who don't go through
the program over 90% of them come back
to prison so it was like an important
story right but it was a Homer Hall of
Fame movie they were not gonna deal with
some of the characters that I wanted to
include like a woman being raped by her
father that's just not what hallmark
does and so I had to really think about
what are the things that are completely
vital to me about this story being told
and understanding that it was going to
be on prime-time television and that it
was going to be told by Homer Hall of
Fame which at the end of the day one to
sell Hallmark cards right so they don't
want to have a rape in other words in
the movie but at that point then the
question that I had to ask myself what
is most important is that getting my way
or is it getting the message out of what
these programs within the prison system
can actually accomplish and being in
television also and you know in a
situation like that
one night 8.5 million people saw that
movie that would not have seen it
otherwise in the big screen so you
battle the battles that you need to
battle and then you really need to think
about what are the things that are most
important it's more important that this
movie actually gets on the air and that
it gets produced it's also really
important that a female writer wrote
that movie that a female director
Darnell Martin produced that movie that
Alicia Keys a female produce that movie
like there's so many other things that
you need to look at that sometimes
having a hundred percent of your vision
it's not the number one priority in
terms of what you want to do thank you
that's great
the strategic compromise every day of my
[ __ ] life I'm trying to keep it
really PC biting my tongue over here
crazy talks about the film as being an
opportunity to be political because it
can be used to break perceptions and
pheenoh I'd like to know if you if you
could speak to that and some of the work
that you've done about being about and
understanding the question I'm sorry
about how they tease political all it
takes politics the opportunities I go a
little holiday takes or politics within
the industry because there are two dirty
things which one would you like to
challenge today well I've tried to keep
that idea in my head how do Latinas
experience Hollywood so I can talk about
my experience here you know I'm
Venezuelan and I started in France and I
made my movies in France in Venezuela so
I was very much a very very hardcore
independent art movie director for until
when you are an art an art movie or
independent movie director the only
limitation you have is the lack of money
so that is the the only
obstacle to your liberty to express what
you want so I made some movies before I
came to Hollywood and I made a movie
called celestial clockwork clockwork
that was selected in sunders and then in
Toronto and I got my little moment of
Fame so they invited me to Hollywood
with many projects and I said wow this
is so easy you know I never thought of
coming to Hollywood before and I came
here like with the red carpet like
invited by everybody you know like many
proposals from studios and I said it is
so easy why didn't I think of this
before
you know they treat you so well you know
I finally I accepted a movie from Fox
Searchlight Oh woman on top with
Penelope Cruz and they were adorable
with me you know I said oh the sky is
blue oh how smart you are
why did I go to France he's so great and
then and then you know and everything
was like a dream like everything was
beautiful everything was great until the
movie came out and when the movie came
out and did it didn't do the numbers
they expected that was it and then I
really met the real Hollywood that is an
industry that is a hard core that is
very difficult there are rules there you
know it's very complex and the best of
the learning I got is that in Hollywood
you have to spend more time in politics
than in a creative thing because you
have to learn how to manage the producer
the executive producer the it's very
complex so I am NOT criticized and I
think I respect the industries and
industries a capitalistic industry so
what's important is the market but it's
important how you sell a movie that is
the truth you cannot take tell yourself
like I did before like art and the
important of authenticity and you know
if I make a movie with the Brazilian
character she has to be actress has to
be Brazilian and we have to put
Brazilian music and you know it doesn't
matter because that somebody said before
I related to everything every of this
wonderful woman said you know like if
you you're not Venezuelan or Mexican you
are brown it doesn't matter if you're
blonde or white you're brown because
you're latina toes that's it
so if you're Brazilian it doesn't matter
to put salsa music because it's Latino
you know it was fascinating for me I
really got like it was a very strong and
humbling process and I I do feel that
things have changed or changed and
slowly from the moment I came here in
2002 today 2017
things have changed they're more women
working on the movies women are heroes
in action movies 20 years ago that
didn't exist you know I think the
audiences are bored of man in action now
they want to see women with much more
interesting to see you know like whoever
all these great actresses doing that my
papa
so I think there's a change and of
course we have some kind of
responsibility but we cannot take all
over ourselves why because there's an
audience there's money inside people
producers they want their money back
they want profit so they're always
terrified when you say oh let's put a
Latino and as a main character a Latina
woman oh my god who's going to buy that
cuz you know who audience are we going
to direct that you know when I chose
Penelope Cruz to make woman on top she
was unknown in that moment here she had
never made an American movie she was
very famous in Europe she was nobody
here and they said to me you have to
take Jennifer Lopez and I said but this
is woman on top
Jennifer start strong we need steel
that's just alone to be a bit you know
and they were like who is Penelope Cruz
and I said this is Penelope Cruz so I
showed you know pits and pieces of
movies and she said you know she's like
a Latino Audrey Hepburn so and so
finally you know they got into this
discussion with Jennifer that I adore I
love her it's not a problem so you have
to feed the character with that and and
she for $15,000 they couldn't get the
so then they turned to me said okay
let's see who's this Penelope I said
she's gonna be a huge star and they
hired her and then the movie it was a
finally movie it was a comedy no
pretension but it didn't work
they expected too much and it didn't
work so I was put into the closet you
know so it's it's hard it I think it's
very complex we cannot simplify like we
have the responsibility I don't think so
i I think I relate the more to Patricia
I think the responsibility is to do your
work as best as possible because behind
you
there are many women who will get you
know if you don't do it well we'll get
the the the bad you know the
consequences of your failing so I think
that we have a lot of things to do but I
think you have to be very ambitious in
the right way you have to be very clear
about the rules in Hollywood very clear
don't lie to yourself that's the way it
is it's the way it is and do your best
the best you can do and compromise if
you can if it's not against your
principles you can compromise if it's
against your principles you cannot
compromise
well I can't maybe somebody else can but
I can't so I think things are moving on
I am very very expensive how you say
that powerful and full of hope that
everything is going to change could I
just talk a little bit about politics on
my little lights
I think in in general like if we can
talk about politics on the other side of
your question is that I think one of the
things that has served me well is that I
have no ego of where my stories are told
and I think a lot of times especially
filmmakers are so eager to tell films
and the reality is that Hollywood is not
making Latino films they're not I just
taught a film development class I teach
at Cal State LA a lot of my students are
here today and one of the classes was
about we broke down all of the major
studios in the film's that they had made
and then three meanie
studios and out of the seven studios
that we looked at not a single one had
made a Latino film in all of 2016 and so
one of the things that I do think we
need to consider as content creators
whether you're a director or a writer or
even an actor an actor it's that
sometimes you have to open different
doors in order to tell your stories so
I've gone from working in primetime
television to preschool and my agent
told me not to take that job my lawyer
told me not to take that job my manager
told me not to take that job that show
was go to you go go it was on the air
for three years I did 60 episodes of the
show and politically politically I was
able to put a young kid who was a
scientist who was teaching kids Spanish
that is political to me and and so if
you focus on just film and I know where
the Academy so nothing about nothing
wrong with no fire and I would have
never been able to be made as a feature
film the last movie that I did about
Kevin Durant's mother where I wanted to
tell a story about a single mother who
got hit her kid to college and another
kid to the NBA that movie would have
never been made
that's a feature film so I think part of
our responsibility is like get rid of
the eagle and really think about where
are the places that your stories can be
told because with so many places where
stories can be told there are the
viewers that can get to those stories
thank you I am gonna have to wrap it up
and we do we're gonna do Q&A but we did
you have a comment I think the other
side to what she's saying is also
looking for financing and funding in
other places so for example the American
system and Hollywood it's all investment
based its private money whereas in
Mexico we have a completely thriving
industry right now tons of films being
made and it's because we have these new
government funds and it's a completely
different model that doesn't necessarily
look at the box office
as the measure of success so for example
for someone like me that I make art
films and I'm not going to appeal to a
mass audience like I can't succeed in
the Hollywood model but there is the
Mexican model for example and there's
also the French and the Germans who are
have their funding that's coming from
the state not from private money and
it's looking for a different kind of
return and I think it's important that
we open up those doors and say maybe one
day Hollywood will decide that they like
the kinds of films I make right but
maybe I don't have to change my films to
fit into Hollywood I have a new movie
coming out in three weeks so if you want
more female directors go buy your ticket
because like she said if the movie makes
money they'll they'll hire more female
directors like you said so it's called
how to break up with your douchebag
comic or Tara to button and it opens
October 13 in the United States and
Mexico thank you thank you
before okay I can take just a little
quest absolutely of all these
magnificent women here who of these
women's are in the and the Academy a
member of the Academy who is in a member
Academy raise your hands high
let's see let's let's see this let's
hope more Latino women aren't getting to
an economy so if somebody wants to
sponsor me I would be very happy and
five or ten years ago we didn't have
this and five or ten years ago we
couldn't have filled this stage the way
we are today it's I am so taken aback
and when I was preparing for this event
just looking at looking at the credits
and the amount of work cumulative ly
that is that is represented here on the
stage it is it's amazing it's humbling
it's inspiring absolutely I want to
thank all of you very much we are gonna
do QA but we have to take a photograph
now I'm told a group photo real quick
because Natalia has to go catch a plane
[Music]
so is that that what is that right and
if someone gonna put this together do I
do this
what's that
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we have microphones
at the end of the center aisles if you
have a question please make your way to
the microphone I want to just
acknowledge right now that both Patricia
Cardosa and Patricia Regan came up
through student-student Academy Award
winners and that's how they were groomed
they came up and our part of the Academy
so we need to acknowledge that and honor
that so now we're gonna open it up just
take questions from the audience and we
have a much longer line on this side so
what's going on with you guys over there
all right we're gonna go ahead and start
with you hello everyone thank you for
being here I wanted to make a question
that probably all of you can answer but
Carmen kuva's you're the casting
director here I I'm a new actress in LA
I've been moved here two years ago and
my dream is to sell tell stories bigger
than the human brain that don't sell sex
and that's what Hollywood wants to see
and I saw the Oh a and it's I cannot I
don't have words to what that says and I
write stories like that for myself and
they're trying to get them out there but
what would you what advice would you
give me to get myself not to be a Latino
actress that sells cooler you know and
and talk about things are bigger than
the mind of the human brain I think the
thing that you said about writing your
own material is the key honestly the key
that can drive you every single day
obviously as an actor certainly starting
out certainly having just moved here you
are having to go on the auditions they
that exists right and and it that also
depends on if you have an age and if you
have a manager and when you get to that
point convincing them like these women
did the you know not everything on the
page that says not everything that you
need to be sent in for needs to be
Latino so I think just those two things
and just really moving forward I feel
like the filmmakers can speak or the
creators can speak more to the to the
writing your own your own way in I say
work really really really hard so that
said which means you're in LA take
classes join groups put scenes with your
friends like you have to be there's so
much competition you have to fight so
hard to get it but you have to prepare
that's the key and actually the other
thing too about the working hard when
you do get apart
it's about it really is for all of us I
think we have to be the best in the room
we have to be the the person that that
everyone else sees works very hard and
then those people know you and then it
sort of spreads from there and and you
know it is about reputation it is about
a circle that you create it's about all
of these things for sure thank you so
much and we're gonna take a question
from you over here hi thank you so much
for providing this forum it's really
wonderful and I'd like to thank my
professor lahia
for making me possible for us to be here
my name is Marie Francois Theodore and
I'm African American but I'm Haitian but
I was raised to be born in Chicago and
I've been here I've been out here for
like five six years I've been I'm a
writer but I'm also an actor and a
filmmaker and I met Natalia actually
years ago at a Women in Film thing we we
were part of a
you want an award together but she's
gone I was gonna say hi but my question
was um mainly about something
interesting happened to me recently with
a casting they were casting an afro
latina
and then they changed it and they made
it that she had to speak with my Spanish
and I have a feeling that it was because
they were getting a lot of Latinas who
basically were white and I know you get
here you're brown but it's not the same
thing so this is all very beautiful and
I love it but I don't see anybody from
Puerto Rico or the dr we're from cuba
okay good
kuba and I'm Haitian but you know me and
the DI we share the same Island so and I
just want to ask about like where the
Gina Torres is are you talking about on
this panel or this panel or just in
general because sometimes when people
say latina they still to me go for a
lighter skin white skinned I very rarely
see a darker skinned well identifiably
black woman up there and I I missed that
and I don't know if that can change in
casting I mean I'm a writer so I will do
my part but I don't know what you what
thoughts you guys may have on it if you
notice if it's the thing in the Latino
community I don't know if it's talked
about if it's a you know okay does
anybody want to speak to that or go for
it work hard like like with everything
else like being a woman or being latina
or being a black latina it's about
showing yourself and you know so we want
them we want them around as soon as we
find them we always try to include them
to let people understand that there's
all the colors of the world in the Latin
world so I'm I'm all for that okay okay
okay I do think that Hollywood sees it's
still very binary everything women its
men but there's you know why am I
forgetting the name Trent is it
transparent on Amazon which I'm watching
the new season and loving right now you
know it's these people having voices
that sort of shatter those ideas Brown
and Boyd and just even in the brown and
the brown you know we know the
difference it's up to us to sort of keep
pushing everyone else to understand what
that is right yeah you just saying it
right now in the room for example I'm
producing a movie and there's the main
one of the main characters the director
said what if she's an afro latina and to
me that was like wow that's um I
actually I agree with you there's not
enough of that and I think just speaking
it voicing it and even if you're doing
an audition and you're doing an audition
for a different role in a movie that
you've been able to read or a script
that you've been able to read and maybe
just hinting like oh you know it would
be really interesting to see if you know
have you guys thought of this everyone
just wants to hear a new idea and I
think that if it hasn't happened enough
people are probably eager to do it they
just don't have that in their periphery
to think about it so I think voicing it
is you know a very important I think
you're absolutely right in voicing is
crucial because oftentimes it's just one
of those aha of course but no one has
ever said it no one no one brought it
out and I think why don't we sell done I
was like one of the most yeah but it
can't just be her stars
I know I know that she made a career
plan african-american women yeah the
counter became an issue yeah but that's
what she's done slow in Spanish yeah
well yeah so I feel like the DR people
like you know when you reference a
really successful yeah she's a lister
yeah yeah I just want to say something
like 100 percent agree with you it's
something that I'm always aware of
whenever I'm speaking to anyone it's
really representing all Latinos so if
you think about spanish-language
television Telemundo no new BC own first
of all everybody's right there right so
that's our first hurdle right with our
own community right right yeah so and if
you think about the East Coast
and the bloggers and the journalists
right because they the kick-ass
journalists on the East Coast a lot of
them are out for Latinas mm-hmm
they're great they're writing in English
and they're telling the best stories so
step by step but I hear you I 100% I'm
aware of that and that's something that
I think just step by step or get there
but yeah it's a problem Judy Reyes okay
yeah all right so we're getting you
thank you thank you for your question
for bringing that up I related to that
question just a comment zoe saldana
who is in guardians of the galaxy which
was the number three movie at the box
office so far this year her father is
Haitian and Dominican Republic and her
mother is from Puerto Rico so she
actually is an African African Latina
people don't know that so if you'd like
say hey like this there's an example
that might help you out so people don't
associate that so thank you for that
clarification of course a question is
yes sir
all right so my question is you
mentioned that anyone with an iPhone can
go make a movie getting together your
your friends are there Latinas who are
using the Internet to basically upload
their films on Vimeo their short films
and getting a following and showing
their craft there if the doors to
Hollywood are not open yet we all can
just go to the internet and upload
content that we've created on our own
and you know show that we can do it are
people using that and if not why not
it's a really good question I mean I
feel like that there are Latinas who are
creating outside of the system and using
new technologies to do that and they're
using different platforms to do that as
well but you might not have heard of
them because these platforms maybe don't
have the same exposure as you know the
traditional platforms do but I think
that there is people are definitely
engaging these spaces and trying to
figure out how to to use those platforms
to get more exposure and to get more
audiences to those platforms and but I
don't you know I still feel like there's
a lot more room for us to
gage those new technologies like that we
we still as a community have I think we
have we need more resources and
encouragement with our young people to
explore these technologies to be able to
tell their stories with these
technologies to you know to inspire them
to use these platforms to be able to
tell their stories I think there's still
a lot more of that education that needs
to be passed on those resources for that
education to happen so I think that that
is that's also I think there's YouTube
bread is starting up there their
platform they are gonna I hope what I'm
saying is not like top secret
information but I think it's know right
it's known they're gonna they're gonna
do their own so yeah and and Facebook
and I think there's anyway there's a
bunch of them Apple go yeah so they're
all you know looking for whether it's
cell phone things or people that have a
voice or have something new or have
something fresh I have a point of view
and there's also blogs saying a short
it's like a two-minute short that I
think Lynne Ramsey did and it's a blog
of just videos uploaded every day and
you can submit videos to those type of
things and that's where you know work is
seen and maybe it's not publicized as
much as as other things but there's
definitely an array of platforms out
there for people like that there's two
girls that make these show I think it's
called two Brown girls yeah and got
picked up by HBO like that yeah so
that's the story right there it was
hilarious if you see it you mean I loved
it so it happens if you make something
good if it would find a way I would also
mention that it depends on what you're
talking about whether you were
specifically referring to scripted
program versus non scripted programming
but if you're talking about anything I
would say that me do which is the
network online is specifically for
Latinos targeting Latinos content made
by Latinos
and Beatrice Acevedo greif is the
president and CEO of that particular
Network so there's a lot a lot of Latino
content creators that put their material
in that Network and there's Spanish and
as well as English so you might want to
check out me too online which is 24
hours of just Latino content awesome
thank you and that will take the
question will be hear from the brave
woman who brought her child yes that's
me
well the babysitter decided that
Saturday was her day
welcome whatever I'm here anyway cuz I
couldn't miss this and I'm very grateful
and thankful to all you guys and to
Randy and to Lou this for putting this
together and this is so galvanizing you
guys and it really resonates with me a
lot of what you guys are saying is
specific with like the advocacy the
inner advocacy for one another inside
that's it you know through the pipeline
authenticity is a lot what I'm hearing
about to being you know true to to not
only the content and and an authentic to
what you're representing but in specific
for how its conveyed and and you know
saying listen a second you know I I have
something to say about what my what my
either character is or how it's on you
know anyway I'm excited so this is great
and my name is Jasmine Campbell and I am
from the Bronx
and I came to LA about a decade ago and
I was behind an agency you know an
agent's desk and did the whole motion
literary picture thing and was crazy and
learned there and it's very interesting
time to be you know a lot Tina you never
and however one thing that I having gone
through the growing up I've also saw you
know people checking the you know the
little boxes the little you know the the
quota and I work in a huge studio now
and I'm a writer but I'm not doing that
there I'm doing I'm finding other ways
to get myself out as a writer although I
have a lot of
individual support the studio as a whole
just is not there yet there's so much
that has to be done in and it's a bit
discouraging but Tilly has points places
like me too they are opening up
development now for scripted programming
where before they did a lot of like
online content and things like that but
they're literally trying to look for or
looking for any kind of any writers they
don't have to be guild or anything like
that
who can also who can also give the that
authentic voice and all that so what my
question is to each and every one of you
what where is that the margin between
becoming you know giving oneself and
being an authentic and telling an
authentic story but also having to as
you as to your point which I never
really thought of it that we kind of
bite the bullet sometimes so that that
way you can at least move up within a
rank so that you can eventually tell the
story you want to tell that to me is is
it's like I feel like I've been doing
that for so long especially having
slaves for someone else for so long and
now I'm so close so I I just would love
to hear what you terrifically talented
people have to say about that I'm gonna
go first okay I want to specifically
talk to you since you know I worked in a
studio for many years as a network
executive
and that's duty executive so I know what
you're going through
for me what's important is that I don't
just look at writing as storytelling I
always ask myself aside from the plot
what is it that I want to say so for me
storytelling is not just and then this
happened and then this happened and then
this happened it really is about a
deeper sense of what is it that I want
to say with a material that I'm writing
and I think if that stays intact what
you want to say
then you can work around them to take
the notes to change characters to change
scenes if that stays intact and so I
would really encourage you as a person
who tell stories to not only think about
the plots that you want to tell but to
really be clear about the things that
you want to explore and that's what you
fight for you fight for the theme you
thought for what it is that you want to
say and if you keep that intact then
there's a lot of stuff that can go away
in the process thank you
we're gonna shift back to this side and
we're gonna we got a lot of questions so
we'll try to keep them kind of concise
and worse
hola my name is Sonia the s and I am at
the beginning of my career as an actress
and this question is gonna be to the
three actresses that are sitting right
here but first before I ask that
question is thank you to each and every
one of you because we are getting
somewhere even though it is a struggle
and I am very happy to have come here
and to have had this opportunity because
I got it at the last minute and I am
very excited to be here because two the
two ladies here I am mexican-american
american-born first-generation I didn't
see my face on TV I saw your face though
and thankful for that
because I thought she's like me like I
look like her oh my god you know so
thank you for that and thank you for I
watched when he VC on growing up all the
time every novela that you have ever
done you know like I I saw it all and I
say that no no
but you know but then when you did you
know economies minora are under the same
moon that was the first time I you know
it was on the big screen and I would
just thought yes
look she's she's getting there and you
know to everybody who was a part of that
like thank you so much because that's
why I'm here because I see people like
you that give me that power sorry to get
emotional and then you're doing great
work I'm seeing I've seen every you know
episode and I agree cuz I did notice
that they didn't put those subtitles and
I was like yes that's right learn
Spanish no no but my question is is that
um how do you approach looking at a
character how do you start
what is your first step when you're
dealing with characters well I think we
are all different in not only each
individual actress or actor and I I
treat every single role different every
character that I play I don't approach
it the same way they speak to me in
different ways
so we all have our way of doing it just
it's just like not you have to you have
to be the character so so it's just
first of all not that they always say
that in acting school right it's like
don't judge your character and when I
played one a human trafficker one with a
movie called trade with Kevin Kline and
it was like one of the worst characters
you know enough characters the role so I
was like how am I gonna approach this
character that is so terrible you know
it's it hurts me and I'm a advocate an
activist of human trafficking so for me
was very and and and then I understood
that she didn't know better
she was also trafficked so so you know
so you start not judging and start just
being and trying to understand why they
do what they do but again that's my
that's the only one but but I mean every
every single character for me is
different the way that I approach yeah I
do a lot of research
like if I'm playing I worked with Peter
Berg and I played a military helicopter
pilot so I interviewed 35 different
people men and women because it was a
very specific you know she flew
Blackhawks and what does that mean when
you are suffering with like you know
post-traumatic syndrome and and all that
my current character on Lucifer I'm a
scientist so I always understand what
I'm saying and and I think you have to
let go of ego so I'm doing it's my first
female lead in this movie it's a Mexican
vigilante superhero movie and I'm very
proud of it it's a 9 million dollar
budget movie and and she's from East LA
leaves to get a degree in comes back and
and I thought you know what I have the
scene where I get up in the morning and
I'm just not gonna get my hair blown out
I'm like I know it's like you know these
big producers and see a package did and
I beat out all the like and and I was
like this character would not have her
hair blown out at 6:00 in the morning
and I washed my hair in semen Sheena
Yale I mean I have like full-on like you
know Indiana hair like ccino ccino ccino
and I said you know what that's that's
how she would roll and I and I
I just put kind of my ego side and and
really wanted to honor what it means to
be born in you know Boyle Heights right
and and I and I was like I gotta give
her wings for another scene because like
you know my girls have their wings and I
think that if you get out of your own
way of like but you still obviously make
it make it your own in in because no one
else can be you but you which is the
beauty right so you don't walk in to
audition and say is this what you want I
never do that I walk in and I'm like
this is what I have this is my gift to
you you drop the mic and you gracefully
walk out the door you know I just so for
me it's like no regrets right my biggest
thing is if you don't do what you wanted
to do you'll always wonder that if you
did if things would have turned out
differently but if you left it all on
the table
and you did your work you do your work
you do your research where they from you
know are they what do they do
and then you throw it all away you just
play in the moment you you become
flexible right if they're giving you
notes or whatever and then like and then
you leave like a [ __ ] baller and and
you just don't it's like I'm it's like
pretend that you were diagnosed with
cancer you would just take all these
risks take all these risks I've thrown
stuff before it's probably it's probably
you know you don't want to hurt people
but I don't care I honestly do not give
a [ __ ] because my job isn't to be polite
my job is to make you do something you
didn't know where you were gonna do I
was doing a scene with Cuba Gooding jr.
it was when my big you know one of my
first big movies he was sexually
molesting me he was super uncomfortable
it was his close-up
and I said he was a cop I was like a
punk skateboarder I said what can I do
to really piss off Cuba Gooding jr. and
this is right after Jerry Maguire he was
on top of the world and I said I'm gonna
spit in his face I didn't tell him I was
gonna spit in his face but I pissed him
off so much he took his prop gun and you
know put it to my head and I could have
gotten fired but I didn't and they kept
that in the movie so don't be polite
just you know just thank you this young
man over here I'll very quickly I'd just
like to thank you guys because I came
here on chance and I'm this lovely
Saturday night I was gonna go out and
give myself a day off but you guys
honestly you guys inspired me so much
with everything that you're saying for
getting gender but just as filmmakers
that I'm gonna go home and get my sweats
and write tonight so and my question has
to go with writing specifically an
apology for the specific but I feel like
yeah you know sometimes I kind of myself
making mistakes because I was born with
the you know the problem of being born a
man and specifically a Latin man which
I'm sure you've all had your experiences
with
[Laughter]
good question yes I know I'll get there
but basically you know I've noticed that
there's like different ways of going
about writing female lead characters or
just characters in general and I was
curious as to which one was more
impactful for you guys considering that
you're the ones that are getting the
screenplays it's coming to you
eventually and I wanted to know what had
more meaning for you what had more
weight which is basically I was hearing
a lot about characters that sort of felt
almost sexless where you could look onto
the page and you couldn't tell if it was
a man or woman and if that was better
and sort of had more weight to it or if
femininity and womanhood had more weight
to it in terms of the perspective of the
character and that that should stay and
that that should be the the building
blocks for the character you know what I
mean and which one of those is more
meaningful to you guys which one's more
impactful which one to kind of maybe
which direction to go for more Carlos
sure right so unlike ability is a big
one because I feel like with women you
always have to be likeable and the
female characters are described and at
least in the scripts that I get
physically their attributes rather than
character attributes and also they seem
to be just likeable and cute and so to
put in to really I you know cuz I even
ask myself the question like why why is
it that they can't they can't seem to
write these female characters sometimes
even women though fall in the trap of it
I I put myself I really do because we've
been bombarded with this these images
and these ideas and talking about
sexuality 38% of Latinas who are on the
screen are half naked or naked that's
more than any of the other races and
ethnicities so we're used to having a
Latina oh my goodness well you've got to
take off her clothes or try I think you
know if you're aware of those statistics
then maybe you're going to start
realizing where it is that we're going
wrong and the perception of what a woman
is with the woman what the commercials
are saying that we should be you know
and what
and what the doctors are saying we
should look like what she should do with
our bodies so getting in the female in
like the same that we do research about
our characters is getting in their shoes
and saying okay what is the stream of
consciousness of a woman she has to walk
down this theater in heels that are
painful and you know and what is she you
know she has to go to the restroom and
get up you know more times than a man
getting into those those shoes are gonna
make all the difference but I think it's
really the work and taking the time to
do it and having the empathy to do it
and asking questions to women to what
I'm sure you're surrounded by women you
must have come from a woman so I think
it's that just having the curiosity in
the empathy thank you
this will have to be our last question
hi thank you so much for all of you guys
being here
my name is Larry Ani I actually went to
a lot Dinah's in Hollywood at CIA back
in April so to see that this
conversation is still continuing I am
very happy I born and raised in
Massachusetts I'm Dominican
so that was brought up earlier today but
I like I said I'm an actress moved here
three months ago but I'm also interested
in directing and also opening my own
production company because I knew
realize that it's the producers who get
a green like the projects that then get
the ball rolling and conversations
starting so I did notice that Natalia
directed and Monica produced everything
else and so my question sorry my
question is
aside from sorry rewind when it comes to
Jane the Virgin when it comes to queen
of the south and when it comes to one
day at a time they are all phenomenal
shows TV shows that are latina heavy
Latino heavy you know but they're all
shows that have been done before so it's
like my question is when it comes to
Hollywood in the content of Latinos that
are being produced it's kind of like do
you not trust the original content that
we have going forward are we going back
to what has worked before and then doing
that forward so my question is when
comes to producing how does one find
funding how does one know how to market
our films in order to be able to then
have original content be shown and tell
Hollywood ok we can do this also ok but
there was a numerous questions in that
question so she packed it in for that
last question we got everybody up there
so marketing who wanted what we want to
talk about marketing the first well
there's a bullet okay what I heard in
terms of Queen of the South clearly you
know lately Dean and ensued is is a very
successful book that was a very
successful soap opera that so David
friendly was the producer of that film
in fact maybe Veronica v Cohen is still
here she's no she's not here okay
so that's that show actually the
english-language version on USA was
because David friendly a non Latino you
know pitched it and and that's where
that happened and then this season
there's a Latino showrunner Natalie
Chaidez and if you watch that show you
can see the difference right it's
amazing to have a nothing a writer and
showrunner okay I'm not answering your
question the next show was one day the
time Norman Lear he's right right
exactly
so all of those shows I think I'm
repeating what you said right all of
those shows have have a what's the
question then marketing yes how do i
market original content of Latinos that
haven't been done before I think that
where Hollywood who can still say okay I
think that this can work instead of
saying well this has worked before so
we'll do it again I mean so coming up
with original programming what you're
talking about versus going back and
revisiting projects that have already
been done and so how do we get Hollywood
to acknowledge that we don't only have
to rely on what has already been done
but how do we then get them to say take
a risk on something that is new yes is
that your question
and how to market that yes complicated I
know it's very complicated
cristela right cristela had a show on
ABC and and that didn't work
unfortunately
there's a bunch of new shows that have
just been announced right that our
development stars is developing a few
stories you're doing okay so she's doing
Vita so I think that we you know it's
it's very complicated but we're not
there yet I mean I mean it's farming dad
part of the problem is that as an
industry they haven't really figured out
how to reach the Latino market and and a
lot of it is because like it was only
until I got to Hollywood that I even
call myself a Latina I've been a Mexican
my entire life
this latina word really happened to be
politically active because there is
power in numbers so it was better to be
a Latina or Latinos and have a group of
people than to be Mexican but nowhere
else where I travel in Latin America
have I ever heard anybody call
themselves Latinos they're argentinos
Chile knows mexicanos Venice Allah knows
Bertolli Kenya's right so they can't
figure it out because we are such a
diverse population so even though we're
fifty million plus strong in the country
there's there's more Latinos in the
United States and the entire population
of Canada in case you don't know that
but it's very difficult with how are we
going to target the Southwest Latinos
versus the Miami Latinos versus the New
York Latinos they haven't figured that
out yet so as a result that is why
you're seeing Queen of the South one day
at a time and the other show that you
mentioned that I can't remember right
now Jane the Virgin because it was their
attempt to figure out okay well this is
a brand at least two of the three our
brands that Latinos already know and
maybe that's the way to pull them into a
show to watch that show and I think you
know for me I'm just much more
interested in telling diverse and
universal stories that haven't you
Latinos than to really be specific about
the audience that I'm going to target
because I don't
Latinos to be the only ones that are
looking at my product I want everybody
to be looking at my product so but to
answer the question that's why it's
happening it's happening because they
don't have them figured it out and they
see with really popular brands and Queen
of the South was the biggest and Jane
the virgin was very popular Betty La Fea
was very popular it was a way to try to
attract a Latino audience that they
don't know how to reach so it was an
easy lazy way out the way the way Samba
did it just really quickly is they
didn't want to buy Betty La Fea so she
decided to go sell it to the advertisers
beforehand so then she went back to ABC
said by the way I've got your whole
lineup of advertisers saying that they
would advertise with this show so do you
still not want the show and then they
got the show made soon and her partner
was Ben Silverman Yeah right so I just
like to be helped and her partner yeah
so all of these executive producers are
Hollywood executive producers that are
know and so you're not getting hired
unless you have a track record and
you're bringing along the athena because
she has to be there and obviously she's
Salma Hayek now but you know it's it's
complicated but what's so great if I can
just add one thing I'm sorry if I can
just add with Queen of the South having
Natalie try this on the show this year
she hired an old Latino writing staff
like that's the importance of getting
somebody in there you know
Tonya is so Tonya sriracha which just
got her her shell greenlit at Stars all
of her heads are Latinos her entire
writing staff is Latino the director of
her pilot is a Latino that's the power
of getting someone that is in the room
and making a decision to be a Latino and
that is exactly kind of going full
circle and how I started out talking
about the fact that unless we're in that
executive suite and then unless we're at
the table knows we're having the we are
able to hire people that we're not going
to have change and as we see that that
is exactly what it's happening it's you
know with any well I'm not gonna go
there because we're really out of time
so thank you all very much for coming
tonight really appreciate all of the
panelists thank you I'm sorry we had
such a little time to talk to each of
you and thank you to Luna this very much
for putting all this together and having
us here tonight tonight's program can be
streamed on the PST la page at the
Oscars org website again tonight's
program can be streamed on the PST la la
page at the Oscars org website thank you